[Music]
thank you
the top story is live from the Sky News
City Studio
the UK pledges hundreds of long-range
attack drones to Ukraine as president
zielinski meets Rishi sunaka checkers
a warning that a lack of government
support is stopping hauliers from
investing in electric vehicle technology
the Black Swan Theory will be asking how
prepared the business world is for the
next financial crisis
plus two-time F1 Champion Mika hakanan
on his design for a new electric
Superbike
when I was a kid I I was always always
requiring a little more but in in
Countryside in Finland and then later on
of course I I end up to racing in a cars
ending up the Formula One
[Music]
good morning this is inking live in our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City where we'll be getting
to the business news in due course but
first president zelens give Ukraine has
arrived in the UK for a surprise visit
he's currently at Checkers meeting the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak it comes as
the UK has promised to send Ukraine more
weapons including hundreds of new attack
drones
there's a lot of great history here in
fact this room that we're standing in
Winston Churchill made many of his
famous speeches in World War II from
this run and in the same way today your
leadership your country's bravery and
fortitude are an inspiration to us or I
look forward to us discussing what more
we can do to support you and your
country this privilege to be here yes
the first time you said not the last
definitely not enough so we of course
we'll we'll discuss very important
issues urgent support for Ukraine and
security for I think not only for
Ukraine it's about for all the Europe so
thank you thank you that you hosting me
and invited me
well we've been asked guys political
correspondent tomorrow Cohen tomorrow
this is all about the weapons
it certainly is in president zielinski
has been on a tour of European capitals
this weekend ahead of a much anticipated
counter-offensive by the ukrainians and
although the UK had already just
announced only last week that we would
be sending Storm Shadow long-range
missiles to Ukraine and the light of
Russia's attacks on infrastructure
energy infrastructure hospitals he's
back today and there's the hug with
Rishi sunak the Prime Minister just says
welcome back uh president zielenski and
the touchdown at Checkers in the
helicopter in the last hour got a warm
welcome from the Prime Minister and
there they are in one of the state rooms
and Rishi sunak explaining that Winston
Churchill had had a lot of his meetings
there during the second world war now
this me this meeting does come with an
announcement
um so we just announced the storm
Shadows last week and today the Prime
Minister will confirm hundreds more air
defense missiles and further unmanned
aerial system systems including
long-range attack drones with a range of
200 kilometers and he'll say that all
this will help Ukraine intensify its
resistance to the ongoing Russian
invasion we know that the UK is also
training thousands of Ukrainian troops
here in the UK president zielinski
visited them on his last visit in
February and there are now we're told 15
000 of them being trained here so it's a
visit that comes with an announcement
about more Weaponry but president
zelenski has said that this is a tour
focused on combat aircraft and his
battle for that continues we know the UK
said earlier this year that giving them
our fighter jet f-35s was fraught with
difficulty because they need years of
training we have facilitated neighboring
countries giving Ukraine some Soviet era
aircraft but president zielinski will
want that to be stepped up if as all the
analysts say he is to make any decisive
progress in the war
thanks Tamara
well if you click on the QR code on the
screen right now that will take you to
our live blog where you can follow all
the latest on President zielinski's
visit and we would of course be bringing
you updates throughout the morning here
on Sky News
but now a lack of government support and
an inadequate public charging network is
stopping hallias from investing in
electric vehicle technology that's a
warning from Logistics UK the trade body
that represents the freight industry it
says that if the logistics sector is to
decarbonize effectively in line with the
government's 2015 Net Zero Target more
support will be needed well joining me
now is Michelle Gardner she's deputy
director of policy at Logistics UK
Michelle welcome to you
um what extent is the UK's van Fleet
currently electrified uh good morning
Ian uh thank you for having me um so
Logistics UK has just published our
electric vehicle reports where we
interviewed 32 of our members to find
out what's happening with electric
vehicles and what they told us was 58 of
them had switched some of their Fleet to
Electric bands in the past two years so
we are seeing a good uptake of electric
bands but the reality is 0.9 of the
total vehicle Fleet is electric
so we still obviously have a substantial
way to go karaki I mean what does it
typically cost an operator to to
switch their Fleet to all electric well
it's significantly more expensive than
diesel equivalents so you've got the
higher cost of the vehicle itself then
you've also got to pay for charging so
at a Depot you will need to put in
charging you also need to maintain the
vehicles plus the big cost for operators
is also power supply so if you're
charging lots of vehicles often at
Depots you will need to increase the
power supply and that can cost anywhere
between a hundred thousand pounds up to
a million so of substantial investment
for operators we had biffer on the
program recently the waste management
company I mean they're they're
converting their existing diesel fleet
to Electric rather than buying new is
that an approach money will take yes I
think we're going to see different
approaches so um either try as a way to
transition so one thing we're talking to
government about is low carbon fuels
because they can drop into vehicles and
actually help to decarbonize up to 80 of
the vehicle Fleet now as well as
adjustments to Vehicles already on the
roads to help operate a switch because
some vehicles are particularly
challenging use cases such as in the
rural areas or where there's not access
to charging so we need to think about
different solutions in the transition to
Net Zero no you're calling for
government support what sort of sums are
you after a it's not necessarily about
sums it's about thinking about what
supports can help the sector transition
more rapidly so Capital allowances for
in tax allowances for Capital
Investments could help with that power
supply challenges and also with the
investment into equipment we also need
longer term certainty on grants so that
when business cases are being planned
they know that those grants for vehicles
will still exist in the years to come
but also it's about that fair and
Equitable solution for power supplies at
Depots that is a real challenge if
you're talking up to a million pounds
for vehicle operators I mean something
might say hang on 2050s 27 years away
why the rush well I know 2050 sounds
like a long way away but the first phase
update for diesel Vans is actually 2030
so about one vehicle life cycle away and
then 2035 for hgv is below 26 tons and
2040 for the largest hdvs do you think
these targets are realistic
by the
ocean but we need to move quicker if
we're going to see the logistics
industry rapidly change to zero taupo
permission Vehicles we need to make sure
the support is there so that's why we're
saying to government help us on our
journey and then we can more rapidly
reduce emissions in the meantime I mean
is there a danger some operators might
shut up shop rather than face expensive
going through all these changes I think
Logistics six operators are facing a lot
of challenges at the moment obviously
High inflation volatile energy costs
other challenges so this is an
additional cost and while our members
are really Keen to decarbonize and we
can see the enthusiasm through our
report and the transition that's already
taking place we just need to give them
the support they need so to make sure
that operators can transition all right
Michelle could leave it there good to
see you this morning thank you thank you
Ian
some other stories now and the US Gold
Mining Company Newmont has agreed a 17.8
billion dollar takeover of Australia's
new Crest mining in a deal that will
create the world's biggest gold mining
company the agreement comes after new
Crest turned down initial approaches
from the U.S business three months ago
Newmont subsequently improved its terms
the deal is the third biggest in history
involving an Australian company well Tom
Palmer newmont's chief executive said
new Crest copper assets had also been a
key reason for wanting to do a deal
shares of Courage have risen by six
percent this morning after the
electrical Goods retailer said profits
during the financial year just ended
would be better than expected Currys
said it now expected to make a pre-tax
profit of between 110 to 120 million
pounds for the year to the end of April
that was up from the 104 million pounds
it was previously guarding the market
towards is that trading in the UK and
Ireland had been better than expected
and particularly during March and April
full year sales on a like-for-light
basis are expected to have been down by
some seven percent on the previous 12
months
British American tobacco's chief
executive Jack Bowles stepped down today
with immediate effects after four years
in the job his departure comes three
weeks after the world's second largest
quoted Tobacco Company agreed to pay U.S
authorities at least 635 million dollars
to settle charges of sanctions busting
in North Korea well Mr Bowles who'd been
with bat for 31 years will be replaced
by the company's Chief Financial Officer
taju Morocco
and shares of Wood Group have slumped by
as much as 35 this morning that was
after the U.S private Equity Firm Apollo
said it did not intend to make an offer
for the Consulting and engineering
company well Apollo which had previously
had five separate takeover approaches
rejected by wood had until this
Wednesday to make a firm offer under
takeover rules its most recent approach
was said to Value wood at just under 1.7
billion pounds while Wood Group which
employs some 35 000 people around the
world said it remained confident in its
strategic Direction and was enjoying
good momentum across all business units
now the Black Swan theory was developed
22 years ago by the mathematician and
former Trader Nassim Nicholas Talib to
describe how to predict events that come
as a shock that have a major impact and
that can only be rationalized afterwards
well the theory has been taken
increasingly seriously by businesses as
they tried to build up resilience but
how do you prepare for a non-predictable
event well that's something that the
business intelligence and software
provider bought International has been
pondering and joining me now is Marco
lamina he's the chief executive of board
International Marco very good morning to
you I mean how can a business adequately
prepare for a Black Swan event because
by definition we're talking about
unknown unknowns almost thank you for
having me here again as I said under the
assumption that no the disruption were
seen since undercovered will be here to
stay we reach out to more than 2 400
international business leader and we ask
them what is about their ability to plan
what we learned that a third of the
businesses say they are now ready to for
the next disruption
however many of the businesses are
investing and are taking this issue very
seriously however plant transformation
are really complex and there are still
some major gaps to be addressed you
mentioned the pandemic there what sort
of lessons have been learned do you
think yeah look at is uh 22 of the
businesses okay are really don't feel
prepared about the next pandemics and
what we're seeing that you know probably
upgrading on the technology capability
is probably the number one element of
that
unfortunately still 98 percent of the
business we interview uh they're using a
very outdated Technologies designed many
years ago for solving problem of the
future
the other one in that element you know
skill gaps uh to get them prepared one
of the key skill gaps we identify is
data analysts a big opportunity either
to you know train the existing Workforce
or to bring from higher educational
skills that can help now to react fast
in the counter those situations so skill
shortages and Technology those the main
two sort of challenges around planning I
would say so what about uh other I mean
the pandemic of course was completely
out of a clear blue sky in terms of it
would have it wouldn't have necessarily
had an issue around data are there other
things like that concerning businesses
so look at now oh we are not in the in
the business of predicting the future
but where we are to give you know
capability to the business to react and
Thrive and what we're seeing that you
know or if you take Gardener or an
analyst you know very well they confirm
that they have some good news now there
is an incredible upside for those
business that that achieve you know
planning agility in fact between those
that can plan at the speed of change and
there's one that plan too slowly no
those one that go faster 198 percent
more likely to take advantage of
opportunity created by the disruption
and only 124 percent
more likely to mitigate those external
events so there is the opportunity and
and that's what we're here to focus
could through here invasion of Ukraine
be described as a Black Swan event look
at uh if I go back to the theory uh we
think about those Blackstone events
those are difficult to predict and
they're very catastrophic consequences
so I would think about you know there
being one the pandemic and a recession
as well were put in the category how
many the modern CEO just has to be uh oh
all sorts of things I mean they've got
to be across the numbers they've got to
be all about the technology future
proving the business it sounds like
they've got to be experts in geopolitics
as well these days no but one thing that
we see from the the result of the survey
and the one of the key element is you
know the decision making the leadership
we say that planning is a team sport
and any organization need to become a
data driven organization make sure that
those inside for planning are available
at all level organization and the CFO
need to get out of the walls of their
department they start working with the
head of supply chain header salesman
marketing and head over no merchandising
so we think about this in
enterprise-wide capability and that's
really differentiator yeah I mean I
guess it goes all the way down to an
organization if you if you think that
every employee is being told to guard
against things like cyber attacks it's
it's something for all people in a
business yeah totally right what I
thought was interesting about your
report though was that there are certain
sectors who are more attuned to this
than others so it looks like the
technology sector and unsurprisingly
financial services are right across this
did you detect a lack of resilience
elsewhere so well we're seeing that the
uh those sectors that are least prepared
according to their answer is catering
Leisure and and Retail we have a lot of
customer particular in retail in Fashion
retail and consumer goods and what we
see that and all those elements that
impact you know ability to spend and
supply chain just impact also this type
of businesses so we work a lot with some
of these businesses and again business
agility plan and react is one of the
elements that allows some to stand out
compared to the pressure there is in the
sector it's a fascinating subject thanks
for talking through with us thank you so
much
well still to come here on Ian King live
we're gonna have a look at how the
markets are doing this Monday morning
don't go away
[Music]
foreign
challenge is a challenge for teenagers
where you create an Alexa skill which is
to help with your Alexa and so mine is
designed to help you recycle so it could
it will so imagine you're cooking and
you've got a piece of plastic and you
your hands are wet you don't have
leaflet nearby you just ask Alexa can I
recycle this I will ask you a series of
questions about if you can recycle the
item or not I think recycling is very
important obviously it leads to the
Future and what happens next in the next
Generations and it's just a very vital
part of our life and how it's going to
develop over the next few years I went
to a camp with stemets when I was seven
years old and also one of the the
founder of semets is Anne Marie and
mafadon who is also one of the judges of
the competition so it's kind of a full
circle nice complete thing and it was it
was quite nice to have the judges as
very important and coding's very
important to me and it's quite vital and
how we develop next Generations so
everyone does computer science in the
school up until year eight and then they
can choose if they want to develop it
but obviously it's very promoted about
how important it is in the future and
that's why Amazon has the future
Engineer program which gives women the
chance to go to a university with
um funding which is 20 000 pounds and
it's 30 women each year and so these
women are given the opportunity to do
computer science or engineering with
extra help from Amazon I think AI should
be used generously and also people
should be taught how to use it
responsibly especially as people come up
with fizz about it but it's definitely
going to become very important and I
just think we need to use it responsibly
I think some people are maybe a bit more
suspicious but then my 90 year old
grandma has an Alexa well used to have
an Alexa and she was able to use it
confidently and she could listen to
music and she could use it and maybe
talk to us through it and so she enjoyed
it and she actually knew how to use it
very confidently
[Music]
well Turkish assets have sold off this
morning amid signs that president
erdogan has a modest lead going into an
expected runoff for the presidency the
Turkish lira has fallen to a two-month
low against the US dollar and is on
cause for its worst one-day fall in six
months Turkish government bonds have
also sold off while the cost of insuring
against the Turkish government default
has jumped to its highest price in six
months on the equity markets well the
knicker in Tokyo was the star performer
in the Asian Pacific region overnight
hitting an 18-month High amid continued
strong company results here in Europe
for most of the uh indices are in
positive territory right now only the
Ibex in Madrid in negative territory
right now talking points in Europe this
morning include AXA the insurer is ahead
by some two and a half percent in Paris
as its quarterly results were well
received well here in London the ftse
100 is also in positive territory right
now up a quarter of one percent on gains
for some of the mining heavyweights
leading Blue Chips higher this morning
is the Gold Miner endeavors up one and
three quarter percent on the back of the
new Crest mining takeover
anglo-american another uh gold mining uh
business up by some two percent in the
same sector
outside the ftse train line by some five
and a half percent that's on supportive
broker Comet it's results a couple of
weeks ago were quite well received
elsewhere in the mid-250 the distributor
diploma group is ahead by just over two
percent that's after it posted a 30 rise
in half-year sales on the downside I
mentioned them earlier on in the program
John Wood the shares off 33 right now
it's the leading mid cap Faller on the
end of those takeover talks on the
foreign exchange markets well Sterling
uh is up a fifth of one percent right
now against the US dollar it's also up
to sixth of one percent nearly against
the Euro The single currency meanwhile
up just under a tenth of one percent
right now against the Greenback as for
the oil price well that's continue to
drift this morning amid ongoing concerns
over global demand I'm gonna borrow the
Brent crew more or less unchanged right
now at 74. 20 cents a barrel joining me
this morning is Russ mold he's the
investment director at AJ Bell Russ good
to see you this morning I mean Turkish
assets do tend to be uh somewhat
volatile as the way you're looking for I
think yeah so the best 100 which is
their the Turkish equivalent of the
footage 100 that's down around three to
four percent this morning and the Lira
continuing a long multi-year slide I
think it was five Lira to the dollar
five years ago now it's nearly 20 and
all of this is down to president
erdogan's what are viewed as unorthodox
policies from a western point of view
he's been insisting Central Bank
Governors cut interest rates at a time
of very very high inflation so interest
rates have come down from 19 to eight
and a half percent over the past couple
of years when inflation's still running
up 40 odds so I think Western investors
were hoping perhaps as well there was
either a steadier hand at the tiller may
be coming in but looks if the election
results can be an awful lot closer than
Western investors were expecting yeah
absolutely it's amazing how resilient a
lot of Turkish companies have had to be
given uh inflation yeah my wife works in
the fashion industry and she's been
dealing with turkey supplies and things
they have to put up with in terms of
currency movements and inflation make it
extremely difficult for them yeah
absolutely well let's talk about some of
the individual company stories around
this morning Curry's uh really took
everyone a bit by surprise I think yeah
they've dished out a few profit warnings
so expectations were quite low the
shares were trading here at 12 months
low but the results a little bit better
than expected some of that's due to an
accounting issue on a debtor but I think
probably the big one there is debt is
down less debt means less risk less risk
can mean a higher share price I think
there's a there's a big sigh of relief
there overall sales are still pretty
difficult in the UK and in the Nordic
region signs may be of a little bit of
improvement in the UK yeah now what
about Wood Group
I don't know whether that's a comment on
Wood Group or I want an Apollo if the
truth details because Apollos had a what
kind of described as a sticky run with
its UK approaches it walks away from thg
walked away from Pearson walked away
from wood missed out on William Hill
when Caesar's entertainment whipped that
from under they missed out on Morrisons
when CD and I beat them to it rumors of
the Sainsbury's bid that never appeared
I think it missed out on went to first
group had a look and walked away so I
guess you can say from their perspective
they're being disciplined they're having
a look they're paying the price down and
then after that that's it we're not
going to budget so maybe he can say that
but equally I'm sure investors in Wood
will be a little bit perplexed as to why
there was a you know a fairly big
premium offered and then then withdrawn
yeah to say the least I mean what was
interesting though is that it took them
five goes to get to the number as well I
mean there's a lot of distraction on
Woods management and Advantage has been
a bit grin on their time and they'll be
looking now to get back to basics I mean
one of the key questions for wooden
hunting which is down in sympathy today
is oil expenditure has been very very
low for a very long time environmental
reasons you know with lots of pressure
on not to drill holes in the years
across lots of pressure on the oil price
that's not been encouraging investment
either when it went negative a couple of
years ago but in theory we're still
addicted to hydrocarbons much as we're
trying to move away from them there are
signs of a little bit of an increase in
activity particularly in America and
wooden hunting would be quite well
placed but Republicans of course are are
pressing for more Shale activity in
exchange for a budget deal in the US so
we'll see what happens yeah we talk
about drilling holes in the Earth's
crust I mean the uh bat chief executive
has fallen through a trapdoor in the
boardroom that's a weird one because the
chief executive leaving with immediate
effect no profit warning No statement of
any kind so that things are going you
know less well than expected not
activists beating the door down
demanding changes so that is an odd one
maybe it's related to the North Korean
sanctions busting fine which you know Mr
bolt has been at the company for a very
very long time is replacement the Chief
Financial Officer today Morocco been
there about four years so knows the
business but doesn't perhaps have that
that Legacy Associated but yeah a weird
one really and oh the only other thing
is Imperial brand Shares are up now
nearly a fifth of the last year bats are
down by something similar so maybe one
or two investors on the board have been
having a little bit of luck at that
Imperial seems to be doing perhaps a bit
of a better job adapting to the Brave
New World of of Vapes and and
e-cigarettes and they have a relatively
new CEO of course they do yeah yeah now
what about another company that's caught
your eye this morning restore it's a
business we've had the CEO on the
program a few times it's a pretty
sensible company the core of it is
storing documents in some Bombshells are
out in Berkshire I think which you know
it's got to be done but they also do
office moves and they do it and
Equipment recycling now I guess office
moves could be a bit quiet at the moment
given that space is not exactly you know
difficult to find and also but it's the
it Recycling business that they've said
has gone slow on them I guess it was a
big upgrading kit that firm has put in
two three years ago because of lockdowns
and I think they're just hanging on to
it and that ties in with a lot of things
we're hearing from the Consultants that
PC sales are down by something like a
quarter year on year which is why you
know people have been waiting for more
profit warnings from a tech sector from
people like apple and Microsoft and
they've not been happening yet but
another sign maybe things aren't quite
as straightforward there as they may
seem slowing PC sales harder square that
with what we heard out of curries I mean
exactly currencies this is the thing and
I guess courage is more retail whereas
restore is more corporate but yeah it is
intriguing which again Microsoft's been
clearly doing brilliantly Apple it's Max
sales were down very very sharp in the
first quarter but it was again dug out
by that wearables and accessories in the
app ecosystem that it's got which just
makes customers so sticky yeah Ross
golly they're always good to see
pleasure thanks a lot
still to come here on Ian King live
I've been speaking to the two-time
Formula One champion Mika hakonan about
his design of a new electric Superbike
if you're into F1 or indeed Superbikes
you don't want to miss this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
just want to show you the latest
pictures that we're getting of President
zielinski's arrival at Checkers which is
obviously the prime minister's grace and
favor home in buckinghamshire there is
Rishi sunac waiting to greet president
zielinski there we are oh friends
reunited
we will have more on that as we get them
these pictures I should say by the way
have been supplied To Us by number 10
Downing streets doubtless there'll be a
lot more over the next few days if you
click on the QR code on the screen
meanwhile and that will take you to our
live blog and uh you can follow all the
latest on President zielinski's visit
there
now recent years have seen growing of
business awareness of the menopause many
businesses have introduced menopause
specific HR policies with some like Bank
of Ireland offering menopause leave to
staff others meanwhile are offering
products and services to cater for the
needs of women going through the
menopause well among them is Nova men's
that gummy vitamin supplement brand
which is launching a range of women's
gummies designed to provide menopausal
support joining me now is Valerie Stark
McQuillan she's board director and chief
marketing officer of Nova men's Valerie
great to see you this morning um what
was the impetus for this
first of all thank you for having me in
we created a comprehensive gummy range
for women and it covers not only
menopause it also covers fertility and
PMs and other General issues that women
experience during their lifetime and the
reason we created specifically our
menopause gummies is to provide women
with a delicious solution that aimed at
supporting their health during this
challenging time in their lives and we
know according to statistics pretty much
100 percent of women but with severe
symptoms 85 percent will experience the
menopausal menopausal symptoms and this
experience is already daunting so we
decided to create something delicious
that can support them during this time I
mean you studied neurosciences has that
informed the approach that you're taking
here absolutely in our formulations for
all three different health concerns
we've created formulations that are
combined tradition and latest
neuroscience and science advances and we
combined herbal medicines and
scientifically studied medicines
together with vitamins and minerals as
well as latest science back bacteria I
mean the menopause affects mental health
as well as physiological Health but it's
the latter that you're you're
essentially trying to treat in the first
instance here these are comprehensive
formulations so we're trying to aim at
all different symptoms and for example
when it comes to the bacteria that we
introduce in our formulations which is
the world's first formulations in agami
form the bacteria aimed at lots of
different symptoms including the
psychological Health what's I mean
without getting too technical on me here
what's the science that underpins this
so for example when we talk about
bacteria bacteria is something that
communicates to our brain and depending
on the balance of bacteria in our gut
our mood can fluctuate and this is what
happens a lot when we approach
menopausal age all right as much work
being done on that the the the imbalance
is in the gut then that happens when a
woman's going through the menopause
absolutely and this connected to the
decrease of estrogen at the same time
it's very important to supply body with
specific bacteria which will get rid of
excess of estrogen there are different
types of estrogen in women's body and
one of the very big challenges right now
in the modern world women exposed to too
much estrogen in the environment through
for example cleaning products and the
makeup so whilst it's important to have
certain amount of estrogen good estrogen
as we call it the bad estrogen Xenia
estrogens should be eliminated in the
body and that's why also it's important
to introduce the friendly bacteria that
does the job as well as mix of vitamins
and mineral minerals such as magnesium
which eliminates the excess of estrogen
that's absolutely fascinating I mean I
had no idea that it was in cleaning
products and things like that why is
that allowed to happen well look a lot
of things that are happening in the
environment and unfortunately unless you
are conscious about yourself and you
consciously eliminate those things from
your life
you know we as women have to face those
issues and one of the issues um that we
often face with those excess estrogen
levels are endometriosis as well and PMS
symptoms value it's a fascinating topic
I wish I could do more with you but
we're out of time I'm afraid good to see
you this morning thank you thank you for
having me
now we've talked a lot on this program
about electric cars and electric trucks
but there's also a burgeoning electric
motorcycle industry and where there are
bikes there are super bikes among the
leading players in the field is The
Finnish company Verge motorcycles its
investors include the Formula One Legend
Mika hakanan and the two times world
champion has just designed a new limited
edition Superbike for the business that
goes on sale today I've been speaking
with him
first of all I'm a huge motorbike fan
and and since when I was a kid I I was
always always writing a little Muppet in
in Countryside in Finland and and then
later on of course I I end up to racing
in the cars ending up the Formula One
and winning a world championship couple
of times so I never really didn't have
opportunity to to Really explore the
motorbike so much but now later on you
know of course I didn't retire already
uh
2001 so that's that's quite a few years
ago so so now I had it through my
friends
connection to network I had an
opportunity to be part of the company
Birds which are making making a electric
super bike and I was fascinated because
the technology what they can create
Innovation what they have and the
Battery Technology and I thought I want
to be part of this this is going to be
amazing and and dear where I am today in
in Monaco opening the shop together with
the words team and and and giving giving
a Monaco to opportunity to have a
amazing Superbike
you had a reputation in F1 for being
quite heavily involved in the car
development clearly you've carried that
into this
you're absolutely right you know the
most of them were catastrophic you know
uh I mean we did develop uh together
with my team at David goldhardt uh
padillo uh with the great designers
Atria new uh you know we we had an
incredible team to to and at that time
when I was Raising Formula One uh the
regulations were much wider and much
more possibilities to do different kind
of Innovations so we we designed in
Formula One uh two brake pedals uh why
two pre two brake pedals because we
always have some technical issue in the
corners with the car so with the second
break but it'll be able to to balance
the car I'm not gonna go the details but
it's just the example other example is
you know with the Innovations I did
mention to
the engineers and designers that way you
know every time when I'm accelerating
out at the corner you know I'm always
feeling I'm a little bit late on the
throttle pedal so can we have the
throttle pedal in the steering so that's
what they did you know they built the
steering wheel you know they built with
the throttle in the steering wheel and
of course it didn't work but but it gave
the indication for the engineers to
found the other way to help me with the
performance of the car so so it was an
incredible time and and uh yeah and so
that's why you know like this this
incredible word motorbike you know the
engine is you know located inside in a
rear wheel uh the battery is extremely
low in a bike that means the center
gravity is low so so the going through
the corners changing direction
overtaking uh for the safety reasons it
is incredibly beautiful to handle so
unbelievable great work from the team
you've talked about some of the design
features there which are the design
features you're most proud of in this
bike
everything everything honestly I think
that the but one of the things of course
that we use a lot of carbon fiber in a
in a bike and also uh what I'm what I'm
really impressed is the is the center
gravity because I know from formula one
that we look you can put the center
gravity low as possible it really gives
you the great opportunity to design the
car with aerodynamically uh that way
with handles great in under braking you
know acceleration in a cornering and and
uh and you know and then then you can
create the great lap times and the
motorbike is the same thing you know so
I would say the center gravity was one
of those things which would make me very
impressed now the bike's going on sale
in a number of European countries
including Germany Italy France Spain
Finland of course and Monaco will UK
customers be able to get their hands on
it if they want one
absolutely absolutely and and me being
in England and raising in British team I
have seen on a roll a lot of motorbikes
and and uh and of course the racing is
in a very popular in in England so
absolutely I mean but I recommend to
have my edition of the bike because that
is super fast
it will be retailing of course at 80 000
Euros it's uh one for uh the sort of
hardcore aficionados
but this is a mega performance I tell
you you can with this bike you can go
roughly about no not roughly 350
kilometers you can charge it in 35
minutes so it has a really top end
qualities and Woody Reflections on the
F1 season thus far
well I I did recognize uh on the start
of the season in a testing testing a
program what the teams had before they
went to First Grand Prix that uh Red
Bull is very strong and and really
reliable uh and and also looking at the
Red Bull car
in a Corners it did look very stable
compared to other teams so I already do
start the season they will they they're
gonna go for it uh so so uh in terms of
that I wish I was supposed that there
would be a great performance coming
coming from the other teams to challenge
the Red Bull but they they really are
dominating uh McLaren really working
hard not definitely not getting results
what they want to have they they
struggling but the team is still they
are extremely positive very confident
that they will get it right and we knew
wind tunnel will help them and
like Zac Brown has said that way
maybe a year maybe maximum two and they
will be there flat out and I'm confident
also with that Zach is a great team
leader they have a great drivers uh and
knowing from my experience you know
we're almost in Formula One and when I
was with McLaren it took me seven years
before I won my first Grand Prix so it
can't be very painful so people very
often forget that that pain what it goes
through the losing but end of day when
you win everything looks good and I'm
confident McLaren will be winning
soon in the future
to another look at this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with news at the
G7 and the EU will ban Russian gas
Imports on routes where Moscow has cut
supplies the measure will prevent the
resumption of Russian Pipeline gas
exports on routes to countries such as
Poland and Germany and of course keep up
economic pressure on Moscow the Ft also
reports on its front page the EU is
coming under mounting pressure from
Europe's biggest derivatives houses to
rethink its plans for taking
euro-denominated clearing away from the
city of London well the times leads its
business pages with the reports that a
project being run by the Outsourcing
company catheter to update technology
behind the BBC's license fee collection
is behind schedule over budget and
considered to be in a critical State the
times also reports that the BP pension
fund is refusing to increase payouts to
retirees despite the bumper profits
being made by the company meanwhile The
Daily Telegraph leads with a report that
Tory MPS are concerned that the
forthcoming renters Reform Bill being
pushed through by the housing secretary
Michael Gove will lead more landlords to
quit the housing rental market Telegraph
also reports that the supermarket Shane
Morrisons has announced a major round of
price Cuts in Essentials such as bread
rolls coffee and corn flakes just days
after Supermarket bosses were asked by
the treasury what they were doing to
bring down food prices who are joining
me this morning is Juliana tuttleban
she's a anchor on our sister channel
CNBC Juliana good to see you this
morning
um talk to me about this ft splash I
mean this feels as though the EU is
basically signing up for more economic
pain well good morning Ian thank you for
having me this story about the EU and
the G7 Banning the restart of Russian
gas flows is largely symbolic you'll
remember back at the start when Russia
and first invaded Ukraine the EU was
reluctant to Target Russian gas flows
because of the immense dependence on
Russia but then Russia cut off those
flows to Europe it essentially got to it
first now this is all about preventing a
quick restart of those gas flows if for
some reason Europe were to turn around
or Russia were to turn around and want
to resume those gas flows this is
essentially saying that won't happen and
the reason for that is partly to give
confidence to those investing in LNG
infrastructure the confidence to put
forward major investment that's needed
to continue this pivot away from Russian
gas toward LNG and if the risk of a
restart of rushing gas flows Russian
Pipeline gas is not there maybe it gives
these investors more confidence to go
for LNG infrastructure that's a good
point one thing though I was slightly
unclear on is where the impetus for this
came from with this initiative well you
know it I will come back to the point
that it feels largely symbolic at this
point given that it won't directly
affect uh flows but Europe wants to
continue taking a hard line the G7 is
taking place this Summit at the end of
this week and this is something that
they can put forward that doesn't have
an immediate impact on the European
economy but does send a signal
absolutely we're talking the European
economy we've just had some updated
growth forecasts yeah this morning the
European commission came out they update
their growth forecast four times a year
and today they have revised up both
their growth and inflation forecasts not
a huge surprise given that the PMI
surveys have been strong of late they
are now looking at growth for the EU of
one percent in 2023 1.7 in 2024 in terms
of what's Driven the uplift there lower
energy prices so tying it back to the
story there we have seen um the price of
uh the price of gas come down
significantly and that's been a boon to
the European economy but there are still
risks on the horizon and as part of this
uh report the European commission says
it downside risks to the economic
Outlook have increased what about
Germany in particular because there's a
lot of concern about Germany stagnating
isn't that there certainly is concern
about Germany stagnating there's also a
lot of focus on the labor market and in
this report the commission note that the
labor market does remain resilient and
inflation pressures remain a problem
core inflation remains elevated and this
is the case in Germany and other major
European economies and on that front
they say inflation is now forecast 5.8
percent in 2023 2.8 percent in 2024 in
the Euro area but they do expect it to
gradually come down as you can see there
goodness I mean that's the implication
so that is the interest rates in the
year is only going to be higher for
longer well it's sort of this story all
over the place that interest rates are
going to remain higher for longer but
nothing compared to the UK where
inflation's still running north of 10 no
we're still the champions of Europe in
uh in terms of inflation aren't we now
what about this story in the telegraph
that Court you're either Morrison story
yeah well partly because of inflation in
the UK and and last week we had the bank
of England come through on Thursday and
uh Andrew Bailey said that the rise in
the cost of food was behind almost all
of the elevated inflation that we've
seen in the last few months so Morrisons
has come out saying that they're cutting
the prices of Breakfast Essentials now
Morrison's roles are actually cheaper
than rolls you can buy at Aldi at
Sainsbury's and Tesco and this move is
interesting because it comes just days
after a number of Supermarket bosses met
with the treasury the treasury
ultimately wanted to understand why are
prices still high and is there anything
you can do to bring them down one
advantage Morrison's has over some of
the other Grocers is they control some
of their food production so they can
adjust prices potentially a little bit
more easily than some of their peers
yeah it looks like clever timing from a
PR perspective on the pot of Morrisons
as well doesn't it certainly does and I
think they're probably trying to gain
market share we've seen Aldi and Lidl
make some major market share gains over
the last several months as people opt
for cheaper alternatives I mean what I
find really interesting about this is
that Morrisons of course is now owned by
private Equity there's been a lot of
speculation that it was loaded up with
that it wouldn't necessarily have the
sort of financial flexibility to do
something like this so it's kind of a
report to that as well isn't it well
certainly and I guess it comes back to
the fact that they do seem to have more
control over their supply chain than
some of their peers but if they are if
we do see a renewed spike in some of the
key commodity inputs it's going to be
hard for Morrisons not to get squeezed
on margins if they keep prices low or
continue to cut prices across further
further parts of the market absolutely
Juliana always good to see you thanks
Ian
and a reminder to check out the Ian King
live podcast which you can find by
scanning the QR code on your screen
right now it's available now wherever
you get your podcast including the Sky
News app Apple and Google podcast and
Spotify
well still to come here on inking live
we're going to be live at Chessington
World of Adventures as it opens its new
world of Jumanji attraction don't go
away
[Music]
thank you Amazon Alexa young Innovative
challenge is a challenge for teenagers
where you create an Alexa skill which is
to help with your Alexa and so mine is
designed to help you recycle so it could
it will so imagine you're cooking and
you've got a piece of plastic and you
your hands are wet you don't have a
leaflet nearby you just ask Alexa can I
recycle this and it'll ask you a series
of questions about if you can recycle
the item or not I think recycling is
very important obviously it leads to the
Future and what happens next in the next
Generations and it's just a very vital
part of our life and how it's going to
develop over the next few years I went
to a camp with stamets when I was seven
years old and also one of the the
founder of summits is Anne Marie and
mafadon who is also one of the judges of
the competition so it's kind of a full
circle nice complete thing and it was it
was quite nice to have the judges as
very important and uh coding's very
important to me and it's quite vital in
how we develop next Generations so
everyone does computer science it's in
the school up until year eight and then
they can choose if they want to develop
it but obviously it's very promoted
about how important it is in the future
and that's why Amazon has the future
Engineer program which gives women the
chance to go to a university with
um funding which is 20 000 pounds and
it's 30 women each year and so these
women are given the opportunity to do
computer science or engineering with
extra help from Amazon I think AI should
be used generously and also people
should be taught how to use it
responsibly especially as people come up
with fizz about it but it's definitely
going to become very important and I
just think we need to use it responsibly
I think some people are maybe a bit more
suspicious but then my 90 year old
grandma has an Alexa or used to have an
Alexa and she was able to use it
confidently and she could listen to
music and she could use it and maybe
talk to us through it and so she enjoyed
it and she actually knew how to use it
very confidently
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back just got a bit of a
breaking news to bring you back some
lines that we've just been getting out
of Moscow during the last two minutes
these are pictures the latest pictures
from uh checkers by the way of uh
president zielinski's visit to uh see
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak um the
Kremlin says that uh President Vladimir
Putin is to hold a meeting of Russia's
Security Council later on today that
meeting has been brought forward from uh
later in the week and the kremlin's also
had some words to say on the latest
British support being given to Ukraine
the Kremlin says British help will not
affect the outcome of Russia's special
military operation in Ukraine that's the
euphemism of course that the Kremlin
uses to describe its invasion of Ukraine
uh the this Kremlin has also said it
takes an extremely negative view of
British military help for Ukraine
they've also been lashing out at uh
Emmanuel macron the French president who
of course uh Mr zielinski visited over
the weekend and during the course of
that meeting president macron said that
uh he felt that Russia was now a vassal
state of uh China and uh it's fair to
say that Kremlin has taken exception
with that form of wording
now from Alton Towers to Legolands the
UK's theme parks will be battling out
for customers this summer as the theme
park business continues to recover post
covid well Chessington World of
Adventures is hoping its new world of
Jumanji attraction which opens this
morning will attract families looking
for a fun day out it costs 17 million
pounds to build and features three new
rides including a new roller coaster
mandrel Mayhem will joining me now live
from Chessington World of Adventures is
ramish guns and he's chessington's
former general manager and currently
divisional director ramish welcome to
you uh this is a huge investment how
quickly do you expect it to pay for
itself
hi an uh live now from will of Jumanji
uh definitely with a multi-million pound
investment bringing Sony and Merlin
together introducing the world of
Jumanji at Chessington definitely we're
looking at a very attractive demand that
will drive attractions and also increase
our attendance locally and
internationally so we're looking at a
quite short span of time uh definitely
for the Breakout
what were the big challenges in putting
it all in place
uh of course we went through the
planning stage itself after that uh
overall it was fantastic it was very
smooth I would say that there's a lot of
uh playing that across various
Department that has gone through so
that's not much of a significant
challenges we have seen uh currently the
the end product that we're seeing now is
where a lot of Joyful screams uh of our
family members coming here creating a
lot of memorable experiences yeah looks
like it's pretty busy there behind you I
thought I thought shouldn't these people
be at school at the moment
yes we do have also School uh kids here
as well with the teachers legally and
also a lot of uh families young family
members are here the park is buzzing uh
we hope to welcome you as well to
experience the mandrel map and probably
in a couple of seconds you would be
seeing mineral ma'am going past behind
me so you're going to be seeing a lot of
uh family screaming
I mean this is built on the land that
there it goes look at that rather than
me I think
um what about it's it's built on a site
that used to be called be no land I
guess that sort of emphasizes how you
keep having to reinvent and reimagine uh
the service and the product that you're
offering
yes that's correct uh as well because of
the consumer segments that we see with
younger generation uh family members
definitely updating our products and
keeping them evolved is really important
to our business you know as we continue
to bring in new products into the market
we are attracting a new consumer
segments which is locally as well and
internationally so that's really helpful
now we talked just now about the
post-pandemic bounce back I mean there's
a lot of talk anecdotally about
so-called Revenge spending how strong is
the pent-up demand that you're seeing
right now
I must say we have had a great season
opening uh since Easter event itself
from April 1st we have seen a
significant growth on our attendance uh
which we are also attracting a new
consumer segment into the into
Chessington and now with the launch of
Jumanji I believe this will be really
strong uh demand for us and consumer
spends tend to be still uh strong uh
what about your costs presumably you are
grappling like everyone else with with
higher inflation right now
yes we do uh the good part is that we
have a lot of uh caliber team members
across the supply chain where we are
negotiating and the good thing is that
UK Merlin we come across with multiple
Parks legal and Windsor alternate hours
we look at how we're doing negotiate
with our suppliers to get the best uh
deal so that end consumers do not uh
fill the high price that they have to
pay for and what about Labor shortages
has that been an issue for you
uh what I hear is that uh last year was
a challenge but this year it's been
amazing we have received a lot of
applicants who's uh wanting to come and
work with us so that's positive uh news
first
all right Ramesh we're going to leave it
there appreciate you joining me today
and the best of luck for the opening
thank you
thank you look forward to welcoming you
yeah
that's it from me for today there's much
more on the Sky News Mobile app and on
the website with reporting video content
and Analysis from our business team if
you look there right now it's a piece I
did on Friday afternoon about the
extradition of Mike Lynch the former
autonomy CEO to the United States a
story of course Broken by my colleague
Mark Kleinman but I'm going to be back
at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning hope very
much to see you then in the meantime do
stay tuned after this short break Jane
second will be up with all the latest on
President zielinski's visit to the
United Kingdom thanks for joining me
today cheerio
foreign
[Music]